share buybacks
they weren't always legal uh but once
companies were green-lighted by congress
uh how did that change the dynamic and
how did dividends play into that a year
ago we were talking about
record levels of of share buybacks
obviously that's
that's dissipated to some extent but if
i follow your data correctly there are
still some big companies out there that
are
still doing buybacks so how have
buybacks evolved
have they influenced dividends and what
can we expect going forward
viaducts did start to come more into bad
when the
regulations were changed for several
reasons companies uh saw them as a
cheap way to protect their earnings they
especially technology they used
options a lot so they would give you an
option to buy the stock
say at thirty dollars the stock was now
years later fifty dollars
uh if you exercise that option my eps go
up and
i'll go go down because my shares go up
so they'd go into the market they would
buy
for fifty dollars you give me the thirty
it only cost me 20.
uh then very quickly after that
companies figured out they can adjust
their earnings
okay and this is why earnings per share
and methodology buyback
need to be an undergraduate course not a
graduate course companies can go in
and buy discretionary in that case it's
usually controlled
more by the board of directors than the
actual day-to-day people
uh because it's so much more expensive i
go in and i buy that full fifty
dollars
okay and i put this share in my treasury
i don't retarget because i can always
use it later in some european countries
you have to use it to lose it but they
put it in the treasury
and my share count now goes down okay
uh and at this point that means my eps
go up
well eps go up that means my pe is less
i'm a bargain
like me before now instead of an 18 p
i have 17.6 uh and we've seen
significant buying and adjusting because
at one point
in 2004 and 2005
uh i and other companies uh put out
messages to our analysts when you do
your estimates
make sure you have the correct shares
because buybacks we do
so many of them but what happened is the
analysts used the wrong shares
and therefore they had a lower eps they
might have the right net
but they had the wrong eps so when that
number came across
the wire at four four o'clock i gotta
beat what am i doing i'm buying
okay and then the cfo and the numbers
come out
it's not a beat it's the share count
adjusting
so literally it was a major problem on
there sec got involved with a whole
bunch of stuff but
uh but buybacks became very popular
uh at one point a quarter of the
companies
brought back enough to significantly
change their eps we believe that four
percent
is a significant amount because again
year-over-year you're comparing my pe
that means my pe has changed four
percent my eps has changed four percent
we did some statistical testing it came
out like the point seven something
good enough make it four percent uh and
so we measure that
and that has gone up uh an average over
other companies so one in five companies
you could typically pick out
that have earnings at a minimum of four
percent
higher because of the eps so this is
impacted
and remember those trades are actual
physical trades because
it's not option trades and gating it's
going to the floor or the system
putting in the trade so you now have
more buy-ins my my stock is worth more
with five buyers than four doesn't
change my stock
so buybacks became an enormous item it's
what
uh in 70s and 80s stock sports were you
announce a big buyback your stock goes
up
you've got support supports my stock it
adds to my eps
is a win-win situation what's happened
now
is that because liquidity is still
remains the main issue
companies that can buy back have high
high cash flow not just earnings but
cash flow
apples microsoft okay they are
continuing and for that
in our last four quarter 82 83 percent
of
the top 20 companies came from eight to
eight three percent of all the buybacks
you either did them or didn't other
companies did not financials dropped
over 90 percent
even after warren went in about five uh
billion dollars in buybacks uh financial
went down because the fed
as you recall came and made comments
shock and dismay within 24 hours the
banks came out and said
i will not buy them the second quarter i
will not buy them for third quarter now
they're not calling them for fourth
quarter
so buybacks as you say went totally down
from the plus 200
to 88 billion last quarter this quarter
i'm looking for better
about 101 billion
uh there is a potential small very small
uh for a buyback bonanza
uh if for some reason the market
perceived that buybacks would be taxed
significantly different next year go
back a couple of weeks to when
a pure biden win was in there
and with including potentially the
senate the house
and and the white house uh and the
concern was that buybacks next year
would be taxed differently companies
couldn't do it so it
might have ended up it doesn't seem the
scenario now
but the item was that use it always
go get them now because you're doing the
actually it's gonna question the same
with dividends
when tax rates went down okay uh
companies did not take a lot of them did
not pay
q4 dividends they paid the beginning of
january
because you as a holder was getting more
getting more well dividend tax
is expected to totally change next year
picture is not clear but if you go
through the agenda's there
it's going to increase so the question
companies had to at least address
internally
i've got a dividend that's going to be
paid out
you know in january do i want to do it
in december
part of the retailers use january of
course on there so do you want to pull
it back
those do not see what's happening uh but
dividend uh
obviously and buybacks are connected
companies have so much to spend
covert of course totally changed
buybacks and dividends
uh companies cash flows cut off like a
light going out if you were a uh
uh a hotel or or something a convention
center or a
travel you got no cash flow and you had
enormous expenses
companies had to prioritize their self
okay
buy back to the last thing typically up
to that point
you want to increase by that should go
to the board and then make a decision do
i want to do it or not i have plenty of
money
they could do whatever they want now
money liquidity was the main issue
because that buybacks took a far back
seat
okay and we're seeing and we see that in
the numbers dividends were a different
situation companies
didn't want to reduce their dividends
poor signaling
those that had to again going back to
the hotels going back
to those that had their cash flow uh
done we saw an enormous increase in
suspensions not cuts but totally shut
off
42 companies in the s p 500 alone
suspended
the dividends not cut but suspended them
because it was an immediate turn off of
cash flow
uh at this point did you're seeing
dividends
still continue we we are going to see a
good year in dividends this year
considering everything
quarter one for dividends was a record
okay
second quarter since so many were
already declared came in very good
q3 went all the way down and q4 bottom
line for the year
uh actual pocket in your money in your
pocket on s p 500 dividends
one percent down given everything that's
a good number for actual dividends
uh but we're seeing in dividends fewer
companies are increasing them and this
is within the 500 as well as the us
common domestic market
fewer increasing and the average
increase
okay for most companies average increase
is significantly been reduced to the 4
area from the 8 and 10 number
those that have good cash flow and still
have have the
money i'm increasing highly so the
microsoft billion and a half dollars
more
uh on there so there are companies again
that have cash flow that are doing
buybacks and not doing dividends
but that's the minority in there all
dividends are holding their own okay
one percent down is not a bad number at
all
it's not the nine and a half percent we
were thinking of at the beginning of the
year and a lot of analysts made that ten
percent because you turn into a nice
double-digit number uh but
one percent considering where we stand
and where we look at things in march
is very good so dividends definitely a
positive item
especially with interest rates so low
now whether it be banks uh bonds
certificates there's nowhere to go if
you're looking for yield you have money
sitting on the side
you're not getting anything you have to
be there because you do not want to be
alternatives you don't want to be in the
market you don't want to be
wherever it is but you are not making
money on the site so yields are one of
the few places to go
uh within the 500 yields of that 1.7 the
index
but for those issues paying it's 2.2
percent which is still a very good
yield however of course there's risk
there's always risk in any investment
and
it does no good to get a good yield
and have your stock tank